all right so let's take a look at how
this falls out the draw sprite function
is given a string representing the name
of the loose acid that we'd like to draw
in order to draw it on the screen the
first thing we have to do is iterate
through all of the sprite sheets that
have already been loaded and determine
whether or not this sprite name exists
on that sprite sheet now to make this a
little bit easier we've actually
abstracted out and created a new
getstats object on our sprite sheet the
getstats function will effectively take
in a name and walk through all of the
sprites for the sheet to determine
whether or not this sprite with that
name exists on this sheet if so it will
go ahead and return the sprite
information if not we'll return null
passing it the sprite information from
the sheet the sheet itself as well as
the position X and position Y passing it
through now drops right internal is
where all the magic happens first we
start at the top of it by defining a few
sanity checks to make sure that someone
else in the codebase isn't calling this
function with improper data next what we
do is actually create a nice little
variable that holds off the center X and
center Y translation value that we
defined when we were loading our asset
next we go to our version of draw image
that has all the fancy parameters from
here we define the source X Y width and
height values passed to us directly from
the sprite object that was defined from
our json Atlas definition the next two
values is that where we want to draw
this sprite to on the destination canvas
that's going to equal to the position X
that we've been given by the calling
function as well as half X and half Y so
that we can actually put the center of
the sprite at the location that we're
interested in drawing in as opposed to
the top-left corner and as we said
before the destination width and height
should be equal to our source width and
height than the sprite atlas